okay
so i'm just gonna say i'm a farmer now
i am incredibly excited about this so i
recently did a big project with best buy
and one of the
items that i got from best buy was this
aero aerogarden and it was a small
little garden that had six little pods i
started growing some herbs i'm putting
fresh herbs in my salads
in my omelets and i never really was
that into cooking but this has actually
made me
very interested in cooking so i thought
why don't i get
an even bigger one and start growing my
own lettuce i eat a lot of salads and
the amount of
lettuce that i normally put in a salad
is probably a serving size for four
people so i go through a lot of lettuce
do you ever think 2020 justine would be
farming and
harvesting her own vegetables no
[Music]
to go from what i started with to this
is very excessive
but if you know me you would not be
surprised
this is called the farm 24 there's
three versions but what's really cool is
these are stackable
[Music]
do you see that this is the one we got
we got the midsize
[Music]
i will make you a salad in three to six
weeks
all right where's these directions
assembly guide
[Music]
okay we might somebody might be getting
lettuce in two years at this point
i can't get this in there get in there
[Music]
let's learn about farming
what are you are these just like some
extension cables potentially
it looks like
[Music]
this is industrial i swear
this looked like half the size on amazon
[Music]
oh these are like magnetic this is great
look at this i just
freaking stick this on here
[Music]
everything is all put together we're
gonna put this into its final home
and start planting
[Music]
wow so bright
all right so here's the problem with
farming
uh i didn't realize how much
water i'm gonna need oh i've spilled
everywhere
i need a hose real farmers have hose
i need hose in this house
oh no what do you know about that farm
lifestyle
so this did come with some seed pods but
i really want to use this
for mostly lettuce so i had ordered some
very specific lettuce pods that i wanted
to make
so here's all the seed pods that it came
with this is kind of like a little salad
bar mix
there's some herbs lettuces and there's
tomatoes
so i do want to try growing some
tomatoes so we've got like cherry
tomatoes
cherry tomatoes oh cherry tomatoes
oh cherry tomatoes so since these are
tall they say to plant
tall things in the back so the app shows
you your light your water level and when
you need to add plant food and this
is the plant food right here and it
tells you how many capfuls you need to
add
do you guys want to see what it looks
like when i turn the lights on you ready
okay here we go wow
it's so bright
it's crazy the light will automatically
turn off and on you can set the timer so
you
if you want it to stay on when it's
daytime and then turn off at night and
this gives you the days that you have
things planted
and since i'm technically probably gonna
plant the rest of my lettuces as soon as
those come in tomorrow
i'm gonna plant one side and get these
started
so i'm going to grow some of the
lettuces that are in this seed pod kit
because i really kind of just want to
test it out
let's do some little
tomatoes in the back
tomatoes in the back that's an heirloom
heirloom cherry out of my other little
herb garden
my favorite herb so far has been the
dill and the basil
but this little seed kit also came with
some chives so i'm gonna put the chives
and i'm gonna grow another set of dill
over on the little dude over there
red sails four to eight days oh we're
gonna get some sprouting
so soon paris island what is that
deer tongue now we put these little caps
on
and you take this off as soon as it
starts sprouting
my babies
four to eight days
seven to 14 days i mean what can i say
there's really a lot of things in this
app that i'm kind of surprised about
there's also a little photo button
so you can take pictures of them so i'm
gonna take a picture this is my
day one use photo
oh my gosh i can this is like tracking
their progress
this is so cool oh i gotta put the plant
food in
okay 12 pods we use four capfuls at
startup
and then two capfuls every two weeks
one two three
four did you like that was that good
did you enjoy your snack do you think
it's like
do you think that if i talk to them
maybe they'll respect me more
it's hard to say we're gonna plant the
chives here instead
and then it's really sad about the
parsley maybe i'll just do like one last
harvest
like i just don't think that parsley is
for me
so look at that here's like the root
system
that grows like right outside of the pod
maybe i'll put the
okay maybe put the chives here he's
probably gonna have some struggle city
with
this basil taking over everything oh
shut up can you believe this
it is i you there's a raising and a
lowering
wow four to six inches
okay my little babies this is as low as
it'll go
this is fascinating make sure you guys
follow me on instagram
and twitter mostly instagram because
i've been sharing updates with my
smaller aerogarden
and i feel like there's going to be a
lot more to report on this one
i'll put a link in the description if
you guys want to check this out and get
more information about it
i'm a huge fan and i cannot wait to have
fresh
lettuce all day long